okay the Trump 20% vague proposal of a
tariff in order to get Mexico to sort of
de facto pay for the Mexican wall is an
absolute and total disaster we have this
proposed twenty percent tariff on the
import of all goods from Mexico to pay
for the wall
Mexico US trade is no small thing some
right-wingers think it doesn't matter
what we do with Mexican trade because
it's not big it's actually huge it would
have a major impact on the American
economy if it was disrupted the u.s. is
a third biggest trading partner is
Mexico one point four billion two-way
trade daily daily common goods produced
a produce cars vehicle parts computers
machines avocados falls under produce
something that could escalate in price
significantly if we start a trade war
with Mexico and this was after both
Donald Trump and the Mexican President
Nieto pulled out of a meeting because
the Mexican president said that Mexico
is just not going to pay for the wall
and then the meeting was cancelled when
that happened I was wondering Pat it of
Trump has been campaigning about what a
great negotiator and deal maker he is
why would you bail on the meeting with
the Mexican president when they say they
wouldn't pay for the wall show up and
negotiate he says he's this great
negotiator don't cancel the meeting show
up and prove how great of a negotiator
he is
yeah I'd imagine the first step of
reaching a deal would have to be getting
those two people in the same room right
I guess he could justify well I can put
it off till later but chop-chop we got
to pay for this so this has obviously
strained us-mexico relations it violates
NAFTA fine Trump says he's going to
renegotiate or pull out of NAFTA hasn't
happened yet and basic economics the
most basic economics tells us that US
consumers and companies are going to be
mostly affected by the consequences of
this tariff especially in American
border states US companies that have
factories on both sides of the border
large amounts of goods imported from
Mexico come from Goods originating in
the United States so this threatens
trade that is crucial to our American
manufacturing companies and including
industries that Trump says he wants to
the automobile industry manufacturing of
all sorts etc this will actually hurt us
global competitiveness and it will also
hurt jobs and it will also allow China
to come in and win again even more which
is what Donald Trump said he would stop
as president of the United States the
other issue is that Mexico could respond
with its own tariffs it could respond
with boycotts of American companies
which are happening and John McCain
Republican senator from Arizona still
somehow ironically the voice of reason
saying quote the free flow of trade has
been the foundation of US economic
policy for decades and a major factor in
prosperity and greatness and then we
also have Senator Lindsey Graham who
said quote simply put any policy
proposal which drives up costs of Corona
tequila or margaritas is a big-time bad
idea
mucho sad of course sort of a joke but
it actually does get at the problem here
not only our price is going to be driven
up which is bad again not so much for
the rich but for the lower and
middle-income people if avocados go up
in price 20% rich people aren't really
going to be affected lower and
middle-income people are going to be
affected there's also a Mexican food
activist group that is saying that's it
we're boycotting McDonald's Walmart
coca-cola Starbucks and yes but not only
are those companies employing people at
their home offices in the US I know that
they also employ Mexican workers that's
more of a reason as to why these a
so-called trade war policies can be so
unpredictable because we have a global
economy we're in a very bad position I
mean best-case scenario is that the cost
of the wall gets put on the US taxpayers
and yet consumers the worst-case
scenario is the trade war and this is
all to support a wall that's really just
not popular among the American public
not popular and also would not be
effective it's again as I said last week
solutions that don't work for problems
that don't exist a lot of people emailed
me and they kind of liked that I do see
it as the sort of motto the de facto
motto of the Trump administration